you
here we go I usually don't end up doing
too good on my very first with my very
first game let's change it let's change
it yeah I'm kidding berserk oh he's
really trying to put a nail in me man
he's trying to put a nail right in me
right in me show him who's boss he's
saying he's saying show him who's boss
who's boss who's the boss okay I already
know who's the boss Ferrari I already
know gonna take the night okay you can
damage my structure yes you are
let's trade Queens maybe I'm gonna keep
my tricky night on I'll keep my Knight
tricky and let's see what you do about
it
oh yes close seconds you better not win
man
keep the Knights on he's tricky you
can't rely on any colour complex no the
Knights are tricky I'm going for a time
burnin strategy that's a check another
check be tricky oh man I think he felt
bad for me he's like I better I better
berserk just to give him a chance just
to give him a chance
Oh I needed this I needed this night
there there's a there's a mate oh my
goodness I finally won a game it took
the berserk though do it oh my goodness
okay
alright a good start with the W I don't
know how fantastic a play that was but
man and even even when he berserks he
gets your heart racing mine at least
it's racing okay what's the story with
that floor hmm what's the big story here
fine
seven look for me castle throw your
queen on h4 playoff five let's tuck my
bishop in here
he likes the a to square you just gonna
have to believe me let's go here I want
to keep my f3 Knight so a knight Knight
here I can do what take with this guy
the Queen night so I'm looking at f5 mmm
also looking at a pretty good time
advantage I'm going to sack on g5
actually let's change that Knight g5
incoming looking for made on h7 h2 s
brother all right this is matin next
main to pretty much unavoidable
well matin one if the RIP moves Bishop
takes f7 GG right back to tournament
land okay two in uh-huh 2000 you know
what you know what Ferrari was probably
expecting me I've just think you have a
doll he was expecting me to berserk but
that's just uh you're really asking for
trouble you're really asking for trouble
if you do that so at least he didn't uh
he didn't berserk this one I don't even
know to do okay I get rid of the night
okay I get the exchange let's go here is
that five gonna hit let's not let's not
allow it um here should I really have
closed it up I get my knight in to f4
he's there and he's there to stay I'll
take like this and then do that
wonderful commentary wonderful let's get
the Queen it's still going to be a
struggle Inbetweeners and stuff and
between errs and stuff
ha trade rooks trade rooks get active
Queen get very active I don't know what
I want to do their bishops pinned just
don't drop your Queen whatever you do
don't drop your Queen I know that's a
classic time burner right there let's
grab here and get out of pins I was
ready to lose stuff
ok the rooks are off this is me who fast
and furious my goodness I had to uh to
call myself there yeah
they lost the Queen by still somehow
felt somehow I felt that I was at a
disadvantage somehow the speed the speed
overrides anything on the board ok let's
break pins let's break those pins guard
B 5 B 4 C 5 so 96 does not hurt me let's
take here do that it should be a shirt
man it should be a shirt take this and
do that for your night on c5 get all
your pieces playing how's your King
feeling on castled on castle my queens
defended though story they're my Kings
comfortable in the center with the
Queen's off throw my knight on c5 play
h5 take with the bishop develop the
developer I didn't realize they just
moved em I like my knight I could take
their Bishop at any moment my bishop on
ei it'll be pretty good let's take him
out next just to stop Bishop here stuff
let's pinpoint that pawn here we go
babysit him now this is collapsing right
here I get the pigs wild pigs let's give
some checks
well they resign back to tournament land
ok this guy's on a tear two three five
four mmm
um if it's really tight towards the end
I mean there's plenty of time here this
is one of the pack leaders a a a yea or
nay um yeah it's definitely one of the
pack leaders here Oh Queen trade clean
trade okay
Oh what was I trying to say yeah I might
need to like bruiser cor something or
something oh okay we're gonna have
trades everywhere trades everywhere all
right clamp down Abbi six do a little
night dancin to be six he's gonna love
that square it's gonna love it let's
take a pit stop here hit there bishop
mmm stop Knight c5 it's a good square um
let's go here I guess my knight is in
some trouble oh they're gonna play here
oh boy hang on I got to negate that
night my knight could be hit um okay I
could I could actually get this pawn
here right I have the square covered
with my knight now I should probably get
out of checks
let's guard my back rank it's not a
happy day here I have to untangle start
with this mm their king is super fast
super fast oh let me get me a king
position here these guys are really fast
though I have a majority
let's get pushing it yep even with the
rooks traded I like hanging on to him
now let's keep going let's take push are
we doing on the clock pretty good I
should have just pushed him again it
should be good now not so fast I might
do a sneaky rook see one move I'm not
doing this so great
here take the pawn and then here
okay get a clean man get a clean and go
fast hey resigning
now steel nights please no stalemates
got it man I had if I had to really
focus on that one okay we're at 18 16 14
13 12 10 John Madden
it's right there in sixth plenty of time
we're only a third of the way done I got
it the Ferrari again man
why'd you keep giving up this pawn all
right I'm not taking the night there is
a great need for speed right here this
guy is an animal animal deny that they
just dropped that guy they're gonna push
me around though I know it
g5 is hitting Oh now's not the time to
think
let's go here I guess I could get hurt
very soon get hurt very very soon my
dark squares are very vulnerable got to
develop my Bishop to f8 okay there
there's your piece back are you happy
are you happy yes I see what's happening
man you're trying to remove that dark
square bishop and then kill me all right
let's come over here just for a moment
grab that phone with check having none
of it oh man
the pain the pain the pain is happening
oh serious pain is happening oh my
goodness why is it time to resign it's
time to resign bag to tournament oh man
you got to stop there silly little F
pawn advance ah okay let's start with
the e for here man even if you're a
piece
doesn't matter this speed kills okay
let's play with the space advantage
Space Invader on d5 let's get some pre
moves in take a page out of the Ferraris
book play like Ferrari get here he
belongs there Knight ones and c4
pressure on d6 space they already moved
I didn't notice that okay I don't want
to stay here too long with my bishop
maybe I'll launch up on up to g5 they
probably don't like that I take away the
f6 square so let's shoot for that let's
make them uncomfortable that's so easy
to get in actually I do have support for
that getting that pond hitting the Queen
and d6 is collapsing take here take with
the night hitting the bishop oh my
goodness I saw things I thought my
bishop was here
oh um wasn't cool at all I have a time
edge it's about it I have a time edge
and that's about it folks watch out for
discoveries watch out for the
discoveries
get out of there Knight you're just
Johnny pests you do realize that I hope
I hope you do yeah he's kicking it to a
higher gear right now I feel it I feel
this speed I don't know defend like that
okay this should be good now objectively
in Oh
back to back Forks those are painful
very painful clothes are back breakers
those uh back to back Forks 17 minutes
remain 27:22
18 ah this guy's on fire
okay how many a lot of other people join
there or I thought there was only like
38 around the start I am mistaken many
more have entered why am I playing the
caro-kann why is my opponent playing the
caro-kann let's let's live in this one
and see what they do about a tricky
night on f4 how are they going to
respond to that Bishop d6 kill the night
not quite
watch out
for dr. Seuss he's back he's back for
just a little bit he can't go too far
yeah let's go here Queen here's maybe
better let's secure c3 pressure here are
they going to Castle the G pun is going
to kill them I'll go Queen side you go
King side deal it's a deal it's a deal
it's happening the H files ripped open
and I'm going right after the king let's
do that seems too good not to do too
good not to do chop chop oh my goodness
no you weren't supposed to do that
abort abort well they had to go into a
pin huh that wasn't cool I wasn't
expecting that one there stone the pin
there stone the pin oh now I have to do
no no they get to take with check Oh 17
seconds I have to be at I'm burning
machine at I'm burning machine give a
check come back here never suspect it
never yes I got the rook that's exactly
what I needed exactly what I needed he's
back in the cane sort of sort of run run
very fast pawn I need you to run like
the wind blows Forrest Gump watch out
for Forrest Gump what is this guy saying
I'm not quite sure there aren't any
answers I got a night the night is gone
no you weren't supposed to go there they
don't have any time though my goodness
less than 15
3124 ooh those top two guys slipped up
leaving an opening we're at the halfway
point in the sakal ski tournament hmm
up-and-comer you gotta watch out for
this guy
this is this is our first time playing
how about that let's make it a good one
let's make it a good one no soup for you
man no soup no soup with beef or hmm I
want to trade LightSquared Bishop s'
let's break in the center change my mind
maybe it still happens oh oh okay I got
a watch over g5 and c5 not fun at all
get out of there my light squares are
really in a world of hurt yep yep I got
a play here and then hit the Queen if my
knight is pushed it's going to happen
actually that's a juicy square they go
the light square Bishop their queen is
restricted or Knight is restricted to
defending here can I rattle their
position we're going to see from my
Queen right here look for made on h2 one
day one day throw my have fun how about
that any issues with tempo I love that I
love those throw upon an f3 okay it
might happen it might happen gotta watch
out okay get rid of night and then made
on g2 I'll take g2 Oh
what are they doing they're in the think
tank that's me g2 i was pressure against
their queen as soon as their
light-square bishop was gone there's a
light squares i lit up in my mind at
least the h 3 f 3 squares vulnerable and
both were occupied at some point
alrighty
you know let's let's maybe play c5 crack
at their center all right let's be
sneaky let's be sneaky with the snake
benoni is that what they call this maybe
the dark square bishop the sneaky snake
everybody loves openings like this right
it's named after a a beast
the polar bear the Sicilian dragon
everybody loves those guys are just so
appealing right so appealing do you
really want to give up that guy really
was important how you getting out this
pin now maybe you're not see for oh I
have enough coverage for this it's still
uncomfortable though it's definitely
still uncomfortable see for Queen b6 if
the king is on g1 I get a check let's
expand opposite sides castling maybe oh
okay I could go here and defend my rook
I have to react with their Bishop I have
checks on the diagonal if my queen is
hit Queen g5 here get another rook
working no matter what I can also take
the pawn but I'm hitting their Knight
rook III Queen takes G oh yeah I'm done
watching I'm done watching whoa what
just happened I'm done watching all this
guy is doing is just making rhymes all
of a sudden I'm here to watch chess now
listen to rhymes take this guy not quite
I need to garden gf5 square mmm let's
take here that way there's a pin kids
are beautiful it's beautiful to put
yourself in a pin there goes a piece and
I'm gonna get hit with a fork just don't
get mated you got a good time edge just
don't get mated whatever happens don't
get made it whose move is it oh they
didn't take my knight over here I don't
have any time anything Fork take a piece
back to tournament ten minutes less than
11 minutes 35 35 28 I think I'm getting
paired up with the fast and furious one
yes there it is my bishop here before
you get your Bishop on that diagonal how
about that
take my poem I'm not getting upon here
doesn't really matter in his eyes
doesn't really matter no it's just all
about speed man it's all about speed
speed and skill speed and skill Queen
trader I get the light square bishop
hmm let's get there dark square bishop
maybe I could go a little faster
let's take here and then their night if
allowed threatened mate east 7 e 6 is
hit to concentrate more against this guy
the night is hit ok I should be able to
get this one should is the keyword
should um let's go here baby step it man
baby step it baby step it defend stuff
here down in the clock here keep pushing
here threaten h6 I already saw that I'm
not doing very well I need to UM faster
get my rook playing how about that a
clean trade trade something ok ok um ok
I see I see the light at the end of the
tunnel finally finally I see the light
at the end of the tunnel keep pressure
on their pawn finally I feel confident
that I could win this one sort of yes I
know how to win this one just move fast
no stay on Knights please no stalemates
automatic check with that coin back to
Turman man and I was up a piece then
it's still it's still a fight and a half
a fight and a half 39:35 32 is where we
stand
ok I need I need to go for I need I need
to go for quicker kills man quicker
kills quicker kills
um okay h-bond I'm calling on you
calling on you man
need to do something let's see how they
take I'm threatening something sneaky
Bishop Bishop a6 sneaky Queen a7 sneaky
it's exactly what I needed 39 36 35 less
than 8 there's a chance there's a chance
we haven't even gotten paired up yet
it's gonna happen b3 best buy test we're
gonna see throw the EEP on Adam see how
they react to find a new home Knight
need to go elsewhere double theme keto a
crowd favorite everybody loves to double
fee and keto everybody I'm going to lose
some material with Queen there know if I
took twice okay I'm playing down upon
but my night is going to turn into a
beast a beast get the bishop pair and
it's as if they're not really playing
with that II pun okay now I get the
material back let's rip the heart out of
their Queen side structure que no watch
out for que no rook takes here
discoveries it's a good move takes pawn
still double up kick their Knight get
back on that diagonal make them feel the
pain now they're hit the rook remove the
defender of e7 get out there oh okay
are we doing on the clock let's try
Bishop in here no matter what
whoo where's their king going its
dislodged their night there they're in
some trouble here there that bishop is a
beast
it's a beastly bishop on e6 there goes
the night let's take care defend here
give a check push c6 this game is not
ending anytime soon
keep pushing take care
not quite let's give a check there grab
the fish
no issues with the back ring can I get a
mate sooner soon right no matter what
there we go back to Turman 550 remaining
43 40 35 33 3 points back I don't think
it's necessary to berserk here oh my
goodness
let's throw the HPI on him let's see see
what he does against the wild h-bomb
that'll throw them off that'll stop him
right in his tracks right in his tracks
uh-huh I'm going to get here right here
on a Castle queenside what's the story
here
let's take here let's put some pressure
let's put some pressure on them hmm
I got castled here how about that don't
drop anything okay please don't drop
anything um let's take here are they
going to take oh I didn't realize if
they didn't pause there I wouldn't have
seen this move that's why they paused
because they had this um I could take
here alright cuz they're gonna pin still
you give a check hmm even on time now
let's take here and let's just do this
there's gonna be perpetual huh maybe
can't I have to have to do something
other than perpetual have to lose a
piece I have to lose a piece let's avoid
a perpetual let's lose a piece instead
no I'm not I'm still up here run rook
really fast really fast
stop that night okay this should be much
clearer now they resigned back to
tournament that was a big win oh this is
a big one four minutes remaining this is
the top dog the top dog and the first
time we're playing let's go um what am I
doing with these moves it's good b5 in a
break with d5
let's pin the night alright let's take
him out control the dark squares get an
e5 their night is restricted well why
not winning some material politics I get
a piece snaky very sneaky okay let's not
think too much about it and their night
take here Oh already I'm going to take
here after night moves I want to go for
this get a passed pawn 95 oh that's what
I was talking about earlier if they took
on e5 trade Queens yes let's go here
what's my night on what's this guy doing
unfortunately I have this move hitting
the bishop hmm I don't like how implying
this okay I dropped a very valuable pone
very valuable
I have tricky Knights though I have
tricky Knights and they are enormous
they're going to land a fork one of them
one of these two is going to save the
day it's going to happen it's happening
somehow they're too good those Knights
there too tricky you cannot avoid a fork
it's going to happen it's going to
happen a fork will hit a fork will hit
very soon very soon one's gonna hit
somehow there it is there it is very
bound to happen oh my goodness
there oh there's a free piece - no
stalemates no stalemates at a time
advantage to GG less than 248 finally to
lead forty eight forty five forty four
but Ferrari oh my goodness really I had
to be paired up with this guy oh wow
let's stop pins and stuff yeah I just
should stop commentating just stop
commentating back up trade okay um I
guess here your night is dangerous these
dangerous piece yeah there it is man
there it is just make me think it's all
you have to do that's all you have to do
man just make me think uh here oh boy oh
boy
yep yep er you had to do it like this
you had to do it like this yeah the
whole farm is falling the whole farm is
falling look how quick those pieces get
back I give them back just like that
yeah just like that
the night oh boy this is this is very
painful it's no good it's no good
mates bishop check out nothing nothing
ah man this is busted yep let's hit that
resigned button ah that's gonna be the
last one oh I still have a lead on
tiebreaks beautiful that's exactly what
I need 48 48 it likes how I did better
time for a tie-break wise there it is
the podium whoa an unexpected finish
first place see I knew it was going to
be I knew it was gonna happen like that
no matter what even if I lost so I
figured I just lose on purpose you know
oh yeah there he goes talking ridiculous
as usual oh wow a nail-biter a
nail-biter gee-gees Oh
who took part in this one I've been
forgetting to go back and check out the
complete players list in these
tournaments I mean to do that to to to
forget let's see
the final standings 4848 definitely a
nail-biter 4848 4538 let's see page 2 3
4 5 6 7 8
those are all the competitors all right
to the 77 of you that took part in this
call ski tournament GG's